In Material Design,
there are two primary forms of visual
feedback in response to touch.
The first is a subtle ripple effect
that radiates outward from your finger,
extending to the bounds of
the surface that it's drawn on.
For borderless elements,
the ripple extends out just enough to
give you a sense of the element's size.
We sometimes call this an ink ripple.
Because we liken to a wave of
digital ink spreading on a surface.
Almost like a droplet of ink falling and
spreading on a piece of paper.
This idea of radial motion emanating
from your fingertip is a key
theme in material design that we'll
touch on more in lesson three.
User initiated radial response not only
puts the user in control of the UI, but
it will make the UI really
satisfying to use as well.
Now, let's look at the second
form of visual feedback.
For smaller interactive
surfaces like buttons,
the surface itself can
lift to meet your finger.
Almost like your finger is
magnetically attracting that surface.
So you see here that the fab rises to
meet my finger as I'm pressing it.